Let's our first bit of
interactivity to this demo.
LibGDX provides a very simple
way to check if a key is
pressed using Gdx.input.isKeyPressed and
passing in a constant from
the keys class like Keys.Z.
If we do this check every frame,
then we can make some change to
the world based on this input.
In this demo the ball
radius is determined by
multiplying a radiusMultiplier
by a BASE_RADIUS.
So we can see, if z is pressed,
we grow the radiusMultiplier
by the RADIUS_GROWTH_RATE.
If x is pressed,
then the radiusMultiplier is
shrunk by the RADIUS_GROWTH_RATE.
Also, we check that the radiusMultiplier
doesn't go below some minimum value.
That way, we don't end up with
invisible balls of negative radius.
Let's give this a try.
So, here's our demo again.
And now, if we hold z, the ball
grows bigger and bigger and bigger.
And if we hold x,
the ball shrinks and shrinks and
shrinks until it's just a point.